okay welcome to begin Abita yeah this is
my Oh way I'm not my comer I'm Ben
Feingold filling in for my comer I can't
really fill in for his shoes but I'll
see what I can do
mike is busy directing the GM Norma vent
boy is he busy I mean he has to like
maybe start the clocks maybe make
announcements occasionally put Kings in
the center on the wrong squares so
that's that's not easy
well the format of the class which is
never followed is that the beginners in
the class bring their games in I wish
there were people strong enough in this
class I could call beginners but we'll
call the beginner beginners sort of like
Ben Simon working the camera is a
beginner beginner yeah there we go
now basically we're going to spend the
whole class saying you should play h6 to
stop everything to g5 every move don't
ever let them play anything to g5 other
way that's Mike's class never mind so
what I do is I looked at games I played
a long time ago before chess even
existed we sort of invented the game
these were played in the early 80s
against people who were slightly lower
rated than me in some cases a thousand
points lower now this game was played in
my first US Open in st. Paul 1982 and I
was white and I was rated a little more
than 200 points higher than my opponent
so you might not recognize the openings
if you follow my chest which you
probably don't anyway because well I was
12 years old so I played different
openings on okay so I play d4 and my
opponent played the Alekhine's defense
I'm sure comer wouldn't like this
because of 'if I've but I didn't play e5
e five would be the best to move and
therefore I didn't play it I played
Knight c3 keeping my opponent on his
toes but then I played e5 and everybody
was happy now luckily black can play
every move in this position Knight d7 is
okay 94 is okay d4 is okay probably
Knight g4 is okay if I haven't seen it
he played 94 and I played Knight back to
e2 confusing all of you
the purpose of this move is actually to
try to trap the knight on e4 the knight
can't escape this way can't escape this
way unless it's intoxicated can't escape
that way and if I can control these two
squares maybe I can take his knight for
free okay he moved his knight away now I
can't take it for free and he moved it
back okay now this game was played when
I was 12 years old
so I played super aggressively now I
would play the most passive move
possible I'm not even sure what that is
h3 a3 but this was was it younger then
so I played ecigs sacrificing a pawn to
make it difficult for his King to get
safe and more importantly to sort of
kill his Bishop on f8 after he takes the
pawn it's hard to move this pawn out of
the way to develop his bishop okay I
played Knight f4 what's the threat
anyone let's call on somebody who's not
paying attention what you aren't paying
attention what's white threatening here
what do I want to do next
take this pawn here this pawn here then
the Queen is trapped so my opponent
played Knight to f6 now his Bishop is
protecting his pawn and I played Bishop
to d3 okay so I'm down a pawn but I have
more development and both of his bishops
are blocked if you ask me why did I make
any certain move I don't know because it
was in 1982 I remember why I did stuff
yesterday okay c5 attacking the center
c3 defending we developed our Knights
okay I attacked his e6 pawn and then I
took it gray okay and now I've won my
pawn back that's pretty awesome
and he took a pawn and this is what we
call a poison pawn and if you've eaten
here before you know what I'm talking
about it's a slow audience today okay
he'll it's slow every day so here black
still has the main issue he's always had
the bishop on f8 they can't move
he can't castle and he decide
to take upon for his troubles now we're
going to learn what as mission Zhuge is
because that's a fun word to learn what
languages wishes look from Danny you
could guess very close you get a border
that's a border country it has Zhuge in
it Meredith yeah we should hug what
language ah but you could guess it would
be funny he said like China that's what
I get from the kids classes exactly not
has Zhuge zu g what German yeah German
now German words missions ugh means in
between move if I take his queen with
the idea of winning a free night free
nights are good he doesn't play pawn
takes Queen what does he play instead
the silence is deafening castle would be
illegal because my queen is is stopping
that so it won't let me
it's a mean computer also you need to
take this Queen you just have to take it
later you have to play it in between mu
before you take it to avoid losing your
night for nothing about half of the
solutions look as our checks because
then if it's check the person has to
deal with that then you can take the
Queen later you did you take the night
check and then you take the Queen and
now black is still up upon so I didn't
play Queen takes Queen
I played Knight takes Knight notice that
my knight is defending my queen that's
fortuitous and if he takes my queen and
I take and I give my bishop way to a
type-o and I take his queen now I am up
at peace I have three pieces and he has
two so he didn't do that
he took my knight okay now if you count
the pawns black is up upon however black
is in a lot of trouble because none of
these pieces have moved the bishop can't
move that none of them can move
and I'm already castled and I have a
leading development and I'm higher rated
and I was younger and you know who full
of fight okay so I played this ship b5
check and he played King to d8 because
if he plays Knight to d7 I can take it I
can take with a queen or the bishop
either way is good okay he'd played King
to d8 and I developed my last piece if I
remember correctly I had to remember
Bishop III now I have all my pieces out
my rooks are connected and I can't say
any of that about blacks position and
White has two bishops
and so forth now we're going to vote
because voting is fun okay you can vote
for black wants to trade Queens black
doesn't want to trade Queens or Pat
Buchanan those are the three things you
can vote for it okay some people vote
for Buchanan by accident a lot of people
are going to vote for Trump by accident
okay mainly bridge players they're like
Trump that sounds good they don't
realize it's an actual person okay so
should black trade Queens who says black
wants to trade Queens who says black
doesn't want to trade Queens it looks
like the whole room votes for a Buchanan
okay what what's that yeah I agree with
that yeah
okay so Buchanan six trading Queens one
they're both good choices black wants to
trade Queens because then he won't get
checkmated White's King is much much
much safer so black played Queen e4 to
trade Queens
if black wants to trade Queens that
means white doesn't want to trade Queens
so did I trade Queens with white I did
not in fact i checkmated my opponent
because that's better than trading
Queens now normally I don't sacrifice
material but I was 12 so I did a lot of
stuff I wasn't supposed to do so I
played Bishop to b6 check that moves
nothing to sneeze there that leads to me
okay he has to take it and I take with
Shaq he has one legal move and I check
him again and instead of blocking with
his Queen and giving his Queen away his
phone ring instead he actually was
forfeited here for his cellphone ringing
it was a very strange incident because
it was 1982 so we were area confused how
the guys fokin ring is really weird okay
he played King zb8
now there's more than one move that wins
I played Bishop to c6 threatening Queen
takes b7 checkmate
would anyone in the audience like to
explain how black stops checkmate in one
what does black do to stop Queen takes
pawn checkmate
move the rook up now he did something
else he resigned but let's move his rook
up because I don't see another way to do
it now
his King can't move off the back rank
because he just put his rook there so
checkmate right although rook a7 does
stop checkmate it allows another one the
only other way to stop checkmate is to
start giving your Queen away which is a
temporary measure then when I take your
Queen I'll checkmate you again so
instead of getting checkmated he
resigned now if this was a Paul Morphy
game I would explain how great white
played and how bad black played but
since it was my game I'll explain it
even more okay White Castle castling is
good White has a rook on the open file
that's good
White has two pieces attacking the black
King that's good
Black has most of his pieces on the back
rank and most of them haven't moved yet
the game's over and black made a lot of
Queen moves which is not good okay so
why did everything right black didn't I
was forced to sacrifice a piece but that
was very safe because these pieces are
just terrible there's actually a book
about this tournament which makes no
sense and this game is in that book just
also makes no sense so if you ever see a
book on the 1982 US Open you'll you'll
see this game ok very suspicious so this
game I was black and this game was
played in 1983 and everything got messed
up control - I don't believe it ok now I
believe it okay and this was played
against Jean Paul page your own even
though it says J page your own I still
remember the guy even though it was
twenty thirty forty a thousand three
thousand years ago
I still remember this game well not the
game I remember the player okay so I
played the Scandinavian or center
counter which I don't play now but okay
and now if my comer was teaching the
class he would be right black for moving
his queen out because the queen keeps
getting attacked and he'd be right okay
now I didn't move my queen iam where I
started moving my minor pieces which
makes more sense let's move our minor
pieces out good good good okay now black
has all of his minor pieces out as does
white now here's something I don't
understand
I'm sure you'll explain it to me being
the beginners you are right Dani so when
I teach chess I say get all your minor
pieces out in castle and my students nod
their head I think they're just
listening to music on their headphones
and they're like yeah and then and then
when they play their game I never see it
it's moved 20 and there's like 30 pawn
moves all the pieces around the back row
and they're like yeah yeah I'll move my
pieces out later okay I'm like what
after you're checkmated when
grandmasters play or masters or
international masters they move all
their pieces out like here and this guy
was probably rated like 1800s old with
all his pieces out he's like yeah you
move all your pieces out okay so he
played Bishop d3 now this guy did
something a lot of weaker players do
which is good for beginner beatdown
a lot of beginners like to trade all of
the pieces than if it's King against
King they won't lose that's their plan
but if you move your pieces out and then
you move them again to trade them you're
not helping your position okay for
example in this position these rooks
aren't on open files and the works
aren't connected it would be nicer if
the rooks were in the center I think you
would agree no matter how good you are
at chess the rook on a1 and f1 isn't
really doing it we got to get our pieces
active
Bishop d3 just trades pieces okay now I
want to win is I'm the highest rated
player in this game of the two of us so
I Castle Wang and now when we castle
opposite sides there's a good chance for
checkmating attacks if we cancel on the
same side and we trade all the pieces it
might be a draw now it draw is unlikely
because we castle opposite wings
okay he played a3 usually that's a bad
move I think he wants to play b4
attacking my queen
I took his bishop he took back and I
played 95 because I didn't see pawn
takes tonight but I was 13 years old so
give me a break
did he play a pawn takes knight what do
you think no don't think so the German
term for this is if don't think so okay
just don't tell any Germans that after
taking I would take his queen now White
has a problem here problem is his Queens
attacked which he obviously sees but my
rook is attacking his pawn so if he
moves his Queen away he would like to
move it where it's defending its pawn
for some reason he didn't do that it the
only square that I see maybe you guys
see more is queen to e3 although I guess
he could have moved his queen backwards
the problem with Queen e3 is this night
is now forking these pieces and pawns my
rook is attacking his bond I think he
should have played Queen to d1 although
his pawn on d4 still pinned so if he did
that I could play something like Queen
b6 threatening basically everything a
lot of stuff is under attack he just
gave his pawn away he played Queen e2
and I was like all right I took his pawn
now some of you are wondering why White
doesn't play Queen takes Knight and the
answer is my Queens defending my knight
so he can't do that
also my rooks attacking his knight he
has to do something about that so he
played Queen e3 now and now you've
probably seen the bumper stickers when
you're driving around here W WMD what
would morphe do yeah so morphe unlike
Brian Boitano who would do something
else yeah what a slow class I mean good
job good class would move his rook
because his rook isn't doing anything in
the corner and the rook is attacked so
rip to d8 now the rook on h8 isn't doing
nothing my
extra double on the open line and I'm a
pawn up ray okay he played b4 attacking
my queen I moved my queen
in fact I have to move my Queen there
because my his Queens attacking my
knight I have to defend my knight Queen
c7 does it
he played Queen c1 somebody asked you
why he played Queen c1 somebody asked I
don't know I think he was afraid of
Knight c4 and then it like for example
let's make a nothing move rook a to
Knight C for attacking his Queen and I
unleash my queen on his Knight so this
would actually win a piece yeah okay so
he played Queen c1 now I did a
discovered double triple uh you know
Lutz with the twist impressing the
judges I have a rook on his knight and
my queen is almost on his Knight that
means if I move my knight anywhere
doesn't matter where anywhere can
legally move then my queen is attacking
his Knight however if I move my knight
he'll move his Knight away unless I move
my knight and put him in check then he
won't move his Knight away because
that's illegal
so I played Knight F free check okay and
this game was played a long time ago so
he was thinking oh give me the knight
which you wouldn't think now because
that songs too old
he took my knight and I took his Inayat
now he's not only is he down upon his
King side is ruined it's not ruined
because family guy wasn't out yet now
here he made a mistake and this is
something you were taught wrong by
everybody especially my comer especially
like if a book said something and my
comer said something they were the same
thing you would believe my comer first
obviously because this is his class and
they would both be wrong about this most
books will tell you most books all books
will tell you when you're ahead material
you should trade okay which is not
correct you should trade if you have a
bad piece and you're trading for a good
peace also when you're trading Queens
you should see who's King is safer who's
King is safer white or black I think
everybody said black black is correct so
white wants to trade Queens then white
won't get checkmated unless you want to
get checkmated which white did so he got
checkmated he played Queen e1 not
trading Queens giving me the f3 pawn
come on
kind of his Queen e1 so he went too far
now how does he defend his H pawn no he
defended it he did King h2 and now I
attacked his pawn again with you at home
incorrect and I heard them Danny what's
the answer
I played rook h4 yeah now it's not
there's good and there's not good that's
not good
there's no way to defend h3 with
checkmate to follow
now obviously Queen h3 is going to lead
to me if he stops Queen h3 with Queen e3
I could just take with the rock and then
I don't know what you prefer I don't
know which mate you like better they're
both good so after Rick age four he
resigned so instead of being a pawn down
the endgame and losing a long game he
decided to get made it quickly in this
position it was very important that he
trades Queens defends his pawn and I'll
have good endgame technique and win
maybe but by not defending his F pawn he
just gets made it immediately terrible
decision on his part that's why it's
beginner beatdown he got beat down it
happens okay now this is a very funny
the story is much funnier than the game
okay now this may confuse some of you
but I was born and this game has to do
with me being born I'm not even kidding
well I'm going to fill you in on it okay
the doctor that delivered me was this
guy the guy I'm playing and my for some
reason my mama my dad thought he was an
OBGYN now he was like a witch doctor
okay so somehow I'm alive somehow but
his name was Howard gaiba he organized
the Motor City open in Detroit for a
thousand years he was a chess player
organizer and director ine was a doctor
he was a very suspicious doctor uh I
don't think as he delivered me because
he basically just gave you penicillin
that was it which worked about 90% of
the time 10% imma kill you but 90% is
pretty good nowadays right and he also
charged $10 if you went to the doctor of
$10 didn't matter what was wrong with
you
$10 not so anyway also occasionally he
would cheat but I don't trust anybody
doesn't cheat a little so so he was
known for cheating a little for
delivering me without being an OBGYN
know I'm alive and also for getting
crushed by me he's known for that too
okay so this game is pretty funny was a
Queens gambit declined as opposed to
being born and declined but I was I'm
alive don't let this fool you can you
zoom in on that yeah you got that you
got it you see it yeah I'm not
Frankenstein I'm a grandmaster yeah okay
yeah I have the white pieces and my
opponent played the ragas in which
wasn't very popular then okay now my
ponen did something which is very
beginner esque
when you have a bishop pending a knight
is that better for the bishop or the
night a bishop because the knight can't
move so often in such situations white
will make a move it will unpin the
knight or he'll attack the bishop and
say hey stop hitting my knight my
opponents like I'm taking the night
anyway so I didn't have to waste time
attacking his bishop that was nice of
him
the problem with treating this bishop is
the bishop that you're left with is a
little suspicious it's blocked by every
pawn all of blacks pawns are on white
squares in there I'll block in the
bishop okay so you
attacked my bishop did I take his knight
or did I maintain the pin-high I tricked
you all now of course the Shiv h4 I
actually have no idea what I did but I
mean I'm me so I played Bishop h4 even
in 1984 I was me no matter what George
has to say about that okay he castled
and a6 doesn't make any sense
now when my opponent plays a6 my
assumption is if I move my Bishop he'll
take and then he'll play b5 and then
he'll develop his Bishop that's my
assumption so I didn't let him do that I
played c5 and the game went on is Bishop
is still terrible g5 I wish you were
better at chess so you would realize how
bad g5 is so someday when you're a
grandmaster come look at this lecture on
youtube look at g5 and go home yeah now
I know what he meant the wall not in
general g5 here's if I had an engine
which I do but it would take me seconds
to find so I'm not going to look for it
they would say g5 is the worst ok g5 now
there's no Kwan's in front of his King
here and I'm ready
I got everything over here to attack his
King now at this game I was 40 actually
it was the Motor City open whoo so I was
15 Wow I was pretty hold this game so I
was 15 years old so I didn't sack
anything if I was like 10 11 12
I would I would have sacked my night but
I'm older now more mature Bishop g3 when
you think been fine go what's the first
word you think mature okay so Bishop g3
Knight e4 I took that guy I put my
knight in the middle and we trade it now
my bishop is pretty good and his bishop
not so much his bishops never going to
be any good also I got h4 I got Queen h5
now based on all of my preachings over
the years I'm sure you've read the good
book by Ben Feingold
what move did black play here which I
say never play f6
yeah now his King has nothing in front
of it okay we're going to take advantage
of that okay he played b5 to get his
Bishop out working and do anything
I played h4 of course we're going to put
it in H we're going to come get him
he played Queen e7 and now I actually
played a good move
I'm actually surprised Meredith can't
believe it if Meredith was here oh hey
okay so normally 99% of you would play
Queen h5 without thinking because the
Queen and rook make a good battery the
problem is the queen is in front of the
rook so after something like Queen g7 if
it was bughouse I could really crush him
but it's regular Chelsea okay so
actually I want my rook in front of my
queen so what move did I play rook h6
now when I play Queen h5 that's annoying
and usually I use my married twice job
when I was 15 here so only married once
no I'm kidding though but over here
twice at 15 yeah okay so my opponent
played Queen g7 attacking my rook and I
played Queen h5 now it's unstoppable
that I'll play rook g6 winning is Queen
you can try to stop it but you can so if
two grandmasters were playing probably
black would resign my opponent played
rook a 7 and this was probably the first
game of my life which would indicate
that later in my life I might be a good
chess player because everybody in this
room including me now would play rook to
g6 which is which is winning I'm not
going to argue ok but I played a better
move I can play rook g6 whenever I want
when my opponent played rook c7 what was
his next we've going to be a rook a
sevens I say c7 rewind the tape gonna
play c6 and his rook can defend his king
I made sure he would never play c6
because I played c6 yeah I'll play rook
g6 when I feel like it now his rook on
a7 is really good
and as Bishop on see it's even better so
I tracked you of his pieces probably not
long probably playing fast and and okay
Ritchie I'm sure computer says rogue g6
is just as good
I would guess if you put it on a
supercomputer it's going to play C six
now because like g6 when I want to and
c6 must have been a good move because he
resigned because he can't move his rook
or his Bishop and I'm going to win his
queen next move so even though I didn't
win any material my queen and rook are
attacking his King pinning his Queen his
rook and Bishop are trapped and also
this bishop didn't get a chance to move
on ca not not a good Bishop this is
actually a big issue in the Queens
gambit declined normally might come er
woody teaches the class is showing
double King pawn openings and somebody's
playing Knight g5 and taking on f7 and
comer gets all upset when I show queen
pawn openings
it's very common the bishop on CA is
being blocked by all these pawns this is
a big issue for black and a lot of queen
pawn openings the bishop doesn't get out
which means the rook doesn't get out and
everybody is unhappy except Wyatt
White's pretty happy okay this is a game
I played in 1986 I was already 23 70
also the Motor City open so I was 16 now
because it was in November what is she
opens over Thanksgiving still exists
okay this game is cool because I let my
opponent trick me and then then there
was trick-or-treat which I guess was a
month before this game okay I played the
caro-kann I guess d3 very suspicious
Knight takes also suspicious and I seize
the initiative immediately f5 h3 what is
this a mite comer class h3 okay Bishop
c5 castles
now I blundered upon which most of you
begin
would take especially Joe Queen takes e5
not because he's a bad chess player but
because Joe has an inferior phone he'd
be thinking about that like I'm my phone
with a pike weenie five bezel they'd be
like oh wait my queen so what would
black do in this position Meredith not
paying attention
talking to the purse I'm making fun of
terrible notice the Queen and King are
sort of lined up here here I'm saying so
what I do look over here on castle over
here
yeah then he's in trouble right okay let
me get my great phone I'll take a
picture of that oh that's awesome okay
so instead he played nine to f3
attacking my pawn now the bishop is a
little suspicious
blocked by his queen and I have a lot of
space in the center so I played 97 again
hoping for this to happen with the same
rookie 8 but he didn't fall for that
he played g3 so he's trying to get his
Bishop out but he sort of blocked this
way she's blowing the other way if I was
white I would castle so that my queen
and king aren't lined up forever if
they're lined up forever eventually I'm
going to do something good
g3 is too slow and I played efore
paulmor if you would be proud of me
opening up the center when my opponent's
king is in the center and I've castled
something I tell my students to do every
game now unfortunately the norm
tournament here has a lot of bad players
okay I'm not going to mention wrong
Burnett's name okay Ron Burnett
yesterday against Andre Goro vets
basically the same thing happened to him
he was white his King was in the center
and the center got opened up and by move
12 the computer said Ron Burnett was
losing okay and usually when your
international master and you're white
you can make it to move 12 usually and
then he played out in a loss position
for 30 moves
look good it was very similar to this
because the center got opened and Robert
Nets King was just sitting in the center
so obviously I could play slowly and
eventually develop my bishop I get my
rook in the center but since his King is
on e 1 we have to punish him immediately
efore opened the center Knight g5 opened
the center now my opponent tricked me oh
now he played the very aggressive the
most aggressive move ever any one Queen
to e6
oh no sorry my king and then he checked
to me forking my king and queen so I
took now his Queens a little funny and
his Kings a little funny so I play
Knight to e5 his Queen has a lot of
squares to go to if you're at home I'm
kidding notice how his queen is attacked
now if white had already castled his
game would be ok but since his queen is
virtually trapped and his king is in the
center he's in a lot of trouble and when
I played pawn takes pawn on g3 I was
hoping he would play for checkmate
unfortunately for him it's the wrong
person getting checkmated my king is
safe is-isn't be posting on my facebook
while making fun of your phone ok I
can't even read it I'm sure it just
agrees with me
ok so he checked me and now he realized
his queen is in trouble where did his
Queen go b3 ok now we got to go get him
Knight f3 oh I played there should be 6
ok is his Queens on b3 man I used to be
good when I was 16 my phone wasn't too
good but I was a good chess player ok so
his queen is defending c2 which is very
important for later in the game when I
check made him and so by playing Bishop
e6 I make his Queen move away from C
- and he's like while the pieces of
piece so he took my bishop but now his
Queens not defending see - if he plays
Queen a4 to maintain the defense I can
just play b5 okay so he's like a pieces
of piece and now I check him he plays
the only legal move too hard for the
class King d1 now I check now he has
three legal moves one of them gets mated
and to lose his queen and I think one
that loses his queen also gets mated
that would be the funniest one so king E
- I have 94 check for King his king and
queen and if he plays King takes
I could also fork his king and queen or
I could play Queen takes check first
then he has to play King be one man his
game looks terrible I don't see how to
made him but it looks terrible I guess
this would be good rook e8 attacking his
Queen and rook e1 Shak that looks pretty
good
not sure if it's better than just
checking and taking his queen ah so many
riches okay he played the worst move but
it ends all of his misery
so James Caan approved when is this game
86 somebody somebody call uh Stephen
King they may get any of that no nothing
nothing in there no he hits your head on
the team it's a book and a movie come on
they made fun of it on Family Guy that
was fine okay so King c1 was played
ending all of his misery
and now his legs were no longer broken
Queen takes D to checkmate
so I didn't win his Queen I didn't faint
I was upset okay and that's checkmate so
I won but this would be six is a cool
move because if I don't play Bishop e6
and just check him first and check him
again now he could take with a queen
defending against the main and now I
would still take black because White's
King is terrible but winning his queen
or meeting him is even better also if I
play Knight f3
and then Bishop e6 he'll probably figure
out what's up he'll be like wait a
minute
something Bad's happening so I played
this should be six first to give more to
think about and now he probably thought
this wasn't very good I think when he
played King c1 he probably saw it was me
but at least he saved his queen what if
he saw it was made and probably not so
in that game why didn't Castle white did
move his pieces out but he did make a
lot of Queen moves
how many Queen Woo's did I make one it
was checkmate yeah yeah you don't want
to move your queen every move then your
other pieces will get mad at you also
you want a castle my king is safe in the
corner my opponent's generally didn't
castle that's why they're featured on
beginner beatdown when you play Mike
comer you know he's going to Castle and
probably play h6 or h3 thank my comer
likes h3 was white the slower the better
now in this game my opponent played h3
and G 3 d3 made a lot of pawn moves but
he didn't castle and he actually had a
lot of chances to castle if we go back
in the game I would have Castle with
white here like every move because then
my Kings then on he won getting
checkmated I would have castled here I
would have castled here and now it's too
late
and here I would have played queen's
eggs d3 and then tried to castle later
and after the and here I would have
Castle although this is getting a little
late in the game but I would but the
knight f7 just loses so he wins material
now for those of you who like winning a
queen you're correct
after King g8 taking the Queen is fun
some of you know smothered mate who
knows smothered mate and more
importantly who knows the difference
between smothered mate and stalemate ok
that's more important that's a question
we get asked here often after 9:00 h6
check all of you are thinking yeah it
smothered me okay you're like smother
mate is the best see smother me see
unfortunately
black can take with a knight and the
rook is defending f7 so if I had played
King 2h if I had played King to g8 I
don't think my opponent would have
wondered his Queen I think he would have
taken my queen with check so what did I
do instead what it black do here I took
the night and then okay now i checkmate
him it's a it's a small difference so
when the king is in the center and other
King is castled the king that's Castle
wants to open the center all the pawns
are gone all the pieces attack your
attack will likely be successful when
your opponent has all their pieces on
the back row here and they've made about
ten Queen moves that I'll teach that guy
to play mean I make fun of them thirty
years later right that'll learn him next
time he'll think twice before getting
paired with me and now as G Wilder is
apt to say class is dismissed
I say class dismissed Gene Wilder's as
is